mais c'est vrai qu'on a tous un souvenir
et moi quand j'avais 26 ans j'étais
jeune journaliste et j'ai eu la chance
d'interviewer johnny vous avez une
interview de johnny interview johnny
brosseau anniversaire pour à l'époque la
couv de direct matin qui est un journal
qui appartient donc aux besoins beau
cadeau pour lui tout sent le mec s'en
fout a priori de direct matin je ne sais
pas le monde sait pas mais si ça bien
qu'il adore je l'appelle parce que on me
donne son numéro téléphone je me dis bon
allez je lance la perche on verra bien
ce qui se passera et il me rappelle et
je vois johnny hallyday renom sur le
portable si je suis tétanisé jeudi matin
mais c'est pas possible
johnny me rappelle et je ne trouve pas
mes mots n'arrivent pas à poser la
première question j'ai 26 ans et johnny
hallyday je me dis mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc et johnny prend une
grande respiration et je sens qui se dit
non mais la pauvre elle a galéré mais
laisse tomber il faut que je la mets pas
l'aise et il me dit tu sais quoi dans la
vie
dans la vie il faut en avoir rien à
[ __ ] et l'or et c'est ça c'est ça
johnny en fait c'est un truc ou après
voilà on est parti sur cette espèce
interview a jugé jean michel maire il a
pris trop de ça aussi
voilà
on est tous d'accord et direct